face à l'envolée des cas de
contamination la rs guadeloupéen
déclenché le plan orsec
objectif désengorger les services
d'urgence un plan en réponse à la hausse
vertigineuse des cas de covile plus de
800 nouvelles contaminations la semaine
dernière alors que le département
d'outre-mer en totalisent un peu plus de
3000 depuis le début de la pandémie en
plus du plan enr san le préfet de la
guadeloupe a annoncé toute une série de
mesures de restriction pour juguler la
propagation du virus
parmi celles ci le port du masque
obligatoire dans l'espace public
un couvre-feu pour les bars et les
restaurants la fermeture des gymnases
piscines stade ou encore des salles des
fêtes des mesures peu réjouissantes
accepter tant bien que mal par les
habitants je pense que l'augmentation
des cas fait quand même prendre
conscience à la population que le virus
il est réel qui ne circule on commence
tous de plus en plus à avoir des gens
proches de nous qui ont le qui attrapent
la coved la reprise après le qu'ovide a
du mal à se mettre en place
on a perdu énormément de 2,2 de clients
les gens
un petit peu de mal à revenir dans les
établissements comme le nom est donc
maintenant si on remet encore en place
des restrictions
ça va nous apporter encore de plus en
plus pour l'année 2020 va être très très
très très compliqué au chu de pointe à
pitre
la situation est très préoccupante
l'établissement est en tension face à
l'afflux de patients à la situation est
très inquiétante puisque tous les
indicateurs sont au rouge les
et au niveau intra hospitalier
notre nation et notre sens critique son
plein on est en train quand on a déjà
préparé une unité de huit lits
supplémentaires pour accueillir d'autres
patients pour les soins critiques si
nécessaire donc c'est très tendu pas en
matériel et en locaux mais en roseau eux
mêmes c'est aussi difficile de
redéployer les personnels on a pu le
faire au prix d'une déprogrammation
partielle de la chirurgie et en dehors
des soins critiques
c'est très tendu aussi puisque nos deux
secteurs qui font du coc vie de son
plein et on est en train d'activer un
troisième secteur 2
deux mannequins pays face à l'urgence de
la situation et pour maintenir les
effectifs
l' ars appelle les personnels médicaux à
ne pas déclencher de mouvements sociaux
dans l'immédiat